in just 10 seconds diodes generate a
laser beam pass-through mirrors moving
as fast as 10 000 millimeters per second
[Music]
this is called a fiber laser and they
can carve super intricate designs into
any metal in just seconds the laser is
essentially getting so hot that the
metal is just vaporizing away like a hot
knife through butter
despite the Laser's ability to cut
through titanium you'll be surprised to
discover waving your hand in front of
the laser does absolutely nothing fiber
lasers simply aren't the right
wavelength to interact with organic
materials at these energy levels we
filmed the laser at regular speed then
in slow motion to reveal what we can't
see with the naked eye
[Music]
you can look almost anywhere in our
modern world and find something that's
been marked by fiber lasers from
consumer electronics to medical devices
maker spaces garages and even small
YouTube Studios
[Music]
fiber lasers start with diodes that turn
electricity into light the light travels
to the laser cavity a portion of the
fiber optic cable that's doped with Rare
Earth elements where broad spectrum
light is transformed into that of a
single wavelength eventually the laser
exits the emitter and is passed on to
the galvo Head where it's reflected by
two mirrors moving as fast as 10 000
millimeters per second which guide the
laser beam to its Target the result a 60
watt beam of focus light that can cut
through titanium and steel
foreign this fiber laser is pulsing
anywhere from twenty thousand to four
hundred thousand times per second and
those pulses are lasting as little as a
billionth of a second
these illustrations are drawn so rapidly
you can only see them sweeping across
the surface with slow motion and the
pulses are so fast that even the highest
speed cameras have trouble capturing
them depending on the material used the
laser can react differently for example
color is only possible on steel whereas
this aluminum can only be marked White
in this clip we're marking aluminum this
is what I would consider a standard
Market the goal here is ablation which
is a fancy word for removing material
from the surface of something generally
aluminum only comes up as white and the
reason for this is because it's a raw
element there's no alloy or other metals
mixed in which means that there's no
room for weird chemical reactions to
occur the galvo mirrors are moving
relatively quickly but they may need to
be slowed down a bit depending on the
reflectivity of the material in order to
ablate it we're using about 48 watts
here which is 80 of our available power
and the Laser's pulsing 25 000 times per
second
because our repetition rate is low it
gives the laser lots of time to charge
up between pulses which means a high
energy beam so that we can actually Chew
in and remove that material
here we're doing what we actually call a
cleaning path so we've dropped the
wattage way down and Blazers pulsing 45
000 times per second raising the number
of pulses per second actually lowers the
amount of time the laser has to charge
up for each pulse which results in a
weaker impact with the material that's
ideal because instead of creating more
mess we're actually using the laser here
to clean up the marking area so that we
get better efficiency on future passes
the low rate of ablation also means that
this is great for pushing debris and
dust out of the way almost like a broom
in this clip we're marking stainless
steel this is where things start to get
really interesting anybody can take a
chainsaw and carve up a forest but this
is the scalpel at work here when metal
gets hot it expands and during these
types of marks we actually have to lock
the metal in place because the laser is
generating so much heat the material
begins to warp dropping the pulse width
from 200 nanoseconds to 175 nanoseconds
in conjunction with lower energy output
just 15 watts here helps to make sure
that we aren't ablating away the
material because we're using a low power
we can actually just heat the surface of
the steel in order to obtain this black
mark the extremely slow scanning speed
of just 50 millimeters per second is
essential here as well it gives those
low powered pulses enough time to
actually heat the surface of the steel
to the perfect temperature for off by
just a few degrees we could end up with
a red or a blue or we could carve into
the surface of the steel which is
definitely not what we want the steel is
one of the only materials that we can
mark with color and that's due to the
fact that the steel is ferrous which
means it contains iron
color marking is the culmination of
everything that we've talked about so
far as precise as we've had to be for
the black marking it's nothing compared
to getting these colors first I have to
point out that we reduced our pulse
width down to six nanoseconds that's six
billionths of a second six billionths
each pulse contains extremely small
amounts of energy but we're pulsing the
laser 300 000 times per second now and
that energy adds up this fragile balance
will apply an absolutely precise amount
of energy to the surface of the metal
resulting in this beautiful color
[Music]
these machines permeate all of our Lives
whether we notice or not they're both a
practical necessity and a hypnotizing
Wonder but most of all they're a
reminder that technology can feel like
magic when you're living in the future
[Music]